che è sta roba ma si può uscire ok
ragazzi sono voglio provare a fare
oddio dio dio dio che cos'è etico che
cosa epica madonna
raga c'è c'è sacchetto paranormal
pattumiera
devo riuscire a non beccare la morte ma
che cazzo ok
ma no
il trampolino sarà sempre comunque fa
[Musica]
calmi
raga è tutto un casino calmissimi ok
capitano ok che cazzo è bacchetta
[Musica]
lo sapevo lo sapevo
si no cazzo cazzo
chi è questo aiuto che esso è sta roba
ok ma che cazzo mi viene la gente
addosso se vaime gaza viene anche tuo
marrone se vai e vai sì o dio che no no
no aiutalo studentessa provare i
risultati ottenuti a farlo entrare nel
college
ok libro di testo non farti beccare però
ok perfetto
ti sei già fatta beckham madonna 6
durata due secondi
allora praticamente ok ok non ci passa è
troppo alto no ci passa ci passa aiuto
allora porca [ __ ] c'è non è possibile
no madonna madonna donna madonna che
cazzo sta facendo
esso non ci posso credere ma si può
essere così [ __ ] che mi sono
cadute le cuffie porca [ __ ]
vado avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti
avanti amati chiamati indietro indietro
indietro indietro in questo livello mi
ispira dal nome c'è insomma ok è stata
una cosa violenta da questa non è la
nutella
mi aspettavo una trappola di ogni genere
ma non è successo niente
porca [ __ ] non perché c'è la
fotocamera laga troppo figo questa roba
vabbè mi sono sì prendi tra la donna che
cazzo ha fatto il bianco è morto va beh
sì poi subito dopo madama
raga qua ci sta tutto
[Musica]
mi spiegate senso di tutto questo voglio
capire perché perché perché madonna mia
posso mai a incentrare il buco minuscolo
sono troppo spaventoso per essere amato
ma no dai poverino tollit lo vedi che
che sei bellissima ok facciamo una bella
cosa eri mettitelo buongiorno sei mica
tu che hai fatto tutto sto casino qui no
perché questa è un'altra multa è quella
che si usano i fogli ma io ti racket
incassi dio ti sto aiutando ti sto
dicendo che si usano i fogli e tu ti
incazzi pure ma che cosa cozzo sexy
[Musica]
non ci riesco sotto alla maniera non c è
fermo fermo mi sa ke kazzo successo dio
oddio aiuto aprite aprite cazzo brutto
bastardo
brutto stop no no
che cazzo muori bastardo mare si sta
seccando
che cazzo è successo ok ok ok ok ok ok
questo nomi con i pip aiuto la galluccio
oddio chiudi apri e chiudi la porta
edizione ma la tengo dalla maniglia così
non entra ok ok ragazzi è un problema
questo c'è il fratello di pif che mi
segue e tieni la valetta porta no no no
no
dovevi pulire casa maledetta
scansafatiche
spiegami come faccia ballare senza gambe
e vabbè andiamo lo stesso vai
perfetto basta la leggenda narra che afa
vj piace la nutella o la patata ma mi
prendete per il culo cioè ok allora
perfetto mai
ma cosa ma la neve ma che cazzo 10 ma
secondo te io preferisco la nutella alla
patata amico mio non hai capito un cazzo
della vita ne avrò dimenticati ma di
sicuro tre o quattro però vabbè c'è
qualcosa da madonna santissima you are
sailing the green box ok e bebè tipo
ideate mi piace né uno non sarà così di
feriti allora vediamo di essere più
vicino a casa
ok ok salve buongiorno mi fa passare che
devo andare nell'altra stanza perché c'è
un taglierino in mano
ok grazie niente va beh ma a un
abbraccio d'amico potevi anche
chiedermelo prima se volevi brutto
stronzo
ok vedo oddio cosa fa sta facendo la
cacca no no no no no no non vogliono
aprire quella maledetta vai via vai via
vai di merda no no no no no no no no no
no cazzo cazzo
ok no no no no no no non ti faccio
niente io io sono qui di passaggio mi
sono svegliato nel letto non c'entro
niente
bravo fai vedere che una gamba nello
stomaco non si scalfisce ok
perché a cazzo neanche le asse mi
scalfiscono oggi io sono highlander
neanche steve che si attacca la mia
testa neanche un tronco d'albero sono
immortale
macchina 0 beh fate passare un treno già
che ci siete guardia no no no no no no
no no non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere non ci credo non ci credo non ci
credo non ho capito di preciso che cosa
dovrei fare
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] cosa vuol dire fare cosa
stai facendo achille non fare cose scene
in pubblico con le tartarughe c'è una
batteria dove prima non c'era prima non
c'era la batteria non c'erano neanche le
mani però avevano anche fame bedi la
cera mense voglio comunque [ __ ]
chi cazzo comitato sul soffitto cosa sta
facendo
che cosa sta questo non è regolare nel
calcio ok riproviamoci ciccia da ragazzo
ho fatto il salto più epico di sempre
[Musica]
ora mi avvicino mi avvicino piano non o
cattive intenzioni ti prego no no questo
mi ispira da dal nome you can start
perfetto grazie che cazzo devo stare o
mio dio e lancio del peso
vai con ri brutto stronzo dio
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok che corri corri
corri corri corri corri corri corri
cazzo cazzo
no no no che perfetto mi sono ricordato
che la roma cade e io oggi voglio sotto
lo stesso
ok madonna che madonna e cazzo ho presa
ma dragare play piano non so se non so
se oggi io che cazzo era
madonna madonna una donna
guarda non lo so che cosa ti ha detto la
mamma ma non si girano di per chernobyl
capitana no è di no si sa die ce la puoi
fare arrivare gli addominali
salvami enti no no le braccia tranquilli
siamo assicuro danimarca
[Musica]
anche la diretta
è la
[Musica]